i'm pops
the mentor
beatboxing is just simply making sounds
with your mouth making music with your
mouth
when beatbox came to saint louis in the
early 80s it was always about emulating
what the dj did so i just started
perfecting my skill as i got older and
then my wife she gets pregnant with
nicole so i would be boxed up against
the belly and nikola started twisting so
you will see my wife belly almost like
she liked it she thought it was funny
and cute and then as nicole got bigger
in the belly it wasn't cute no more at
the age of 13 was my first talent show i
just went home and i said
pops i just joined the talent show
you're gonna teach me how to beatbox he
taught me how to hold the mic taught me
how to breathe taught me the basic beat
i went to the talent show did that they
made me mad at the talent show they was
clapping off beat
and it was like
i then started to add my own thing to
what he taught me one night i came home
from work and as i'm walking in the door
i heard her making all these strange
noise i had to tell them like that's not
beatboxing no i don't do that that's
corny i was like
what
this is when i had to realize and tell
myself look this is what she wants to do
me and pops we be boxed anywhere all day
don't even make a difference no it
really don't be boxed by cooking
barbershop
when we're ready to beatbox it literally
happens doesn't matter if you go to her
youtube channel you will see us sitting
down be boxing into some folks and it
can look like a competition oh my god
we're not really battling it's just this
just jam session just us having fun this
this is how i bond with my child even
though even though 160 million people be
like
pop loser
i want her to be the best i want her to
to out do me not and i'll do me like as
in a battle but i want her to just just
continue to grow and add to beatboxing
[Music]
you